good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm jesse waters the justice
system did its job today in kenosha
after 25 long hours of deliberation the
jury finally delivered a verdict in the
case of kyle rittenhouse so the fifth
count of the information gage rose croix
we the jury find the defendant kyle
avery kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
members of the jury are these your
unanimous verdicts
is there anyone who does not agree with
the verdicts as read
not guilty on all charges inside the
courtroom happy tears from kyle
rittenhouse and his family but outside
the courthouse was another story
protesters angry at the verdict jacob
blake's family wasting no time playing
the race card
you know his ideology they talk about
harming african-americans they talk
about hiring minorities and he acted it
out now you tell us why he got a free
ride his barrel money was raised by the
proud boys the ku klux klan
uh the nazis the skinheads
are they plugged up in this courtroom
do we know the history of this judge i
heard he's been racist as hell that
means these people in kenosha for many
years
the angry mob didn't get its way so time
to blame the judge who's a democrat
time to blame racism
kyle didn't shoot anybody black
and this reaction isn't just coming from
protesters outside the courthouse no
prominent leftists around the country
are losing their minds over the verdict
congresswoman corey bush tweeting
this system isn't built to hold white
supremacists accountable it's why black
and brown folks are brutalized and put
in cages while white supremacist
murderers walk free
the pinheads at msnbc chimed in saying
kyle rittenhouse trial was designed to
protect white conservatives who kill
and then you have this lady we saw
similar outcomes with emmett till we've
seen similar outcomes with lynch mobs
there is a distinct pattern in this
country and in this criminal legal
system that will allow protect and
defend the in particular white men who
will defend uh white supremacy and the
culture of white supremacy that
permeates this entire country and let's
be clear this judge as paul pointed out
earlier was brazen in his in the way
that he put his thumb on this scale he
rubbed our noses in the fact that he
could do whatever he wanted and
basically dared us to do anything about
it he wanted us to be very clear that he
would stop at nothing to defend this
blueprint for white supremacist
vigilantism
it's his idiocy don't listen to this
garbage
we should all sleep better tonight
knowing that the rule of law still
exists the jury had a difficult task
but they listened to the evidence and
justice prevailed
just in terms of your
the attentiveness and the cooperation
that you gave to us
this
justifies the confidence
that the founders of our country placed
in you
a lot was riding on this decision by the
jury it wasn't just about the innocence
of kyle rittenhouse it was also about
our second amendment and the right to
self-defense
had the verdict gone the other way those
rights would have been seriously wounded
but the justice system came through and
now we must all
respect it even joe biden knows that
don't stand by your
past comments
well look i stand by what the jury has
concluded the jury system works and you
have to abide by it
but this isn't a case of better late
than never joe biden can't undo the
damage he caused kyle rittenhouse when
he smeared the kid as a white
supremacist just so he could win an
election
biden's handlers released a statement
later kind of cleaning things up reading
while the verdict in kenosha will leave
many americans feeling angry and
concerned myself included we must
acknowledge that the jury's spoken i
urge everybody to express their views
peacefully consistent with the rule of
law violence and destruction of property
have no place in our democracy
but will the protesters in kenosha
listen
500 national guard troops are standing
by in case chaos erupts but so far
things are actually mostly peaceful hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else